a gente brincava também era do Cola só
que eu man eu sempre fui mais
pequenininho Man mais branquinho E aí os
Car me botava PR ser café com
leite e Mas você café com leite é p é
demais cara para quem não conhece o café
com leite é a cota pra criança na
brincadeira geralmente todo mundo que tá
brincando do Cola que é aquela
brincadeira de correr e triscar na
pessoa se triscou colou a pessoa né
então quem tá brincando essa brincadeira
geralmente tem 14 anos agora os caba que
tem oito quer brincar também aí eles
bota nós como café com leite ou seja a
gente não tem importância ninguém corta
da gente porque a gente não tem
importância a gente é só uma peça cara
uma engrenagem a gente é só uma
marionete na mão do sistema cara então
tá todo mundo brincando tá todo mundo
correndo tá todo mundo feliz e eu tô
como devagar porque eu sou o qu café com
leite você não tem noção do que é que é
uma merda o cara ser um café com leite
não mano quando você é o café com leite
a brincadeira fica mais ou menos assim
vou pegar eu vou pegar e você fica assim
[Música]
ó